I have to say dolly when I was watching
this movie I was singing throughout the
whole thing I'm sure you were too mm-hmm
so when you when they approached you
about having a movie with like your
songs kind of as the soundtrack in the
driving force honored were you for this
opportunity very honor yeah even when
the book came out I was just so honored
you know there was a book that had my
name in it talked about me and talked
about my music and then when they asked
if I would write some additional music
for it I was more than happy to do this
so it was a great honor and it was a lot
of fun - we had a good time doing that
welcome with Linda Perry and she even
came to sing with me I'm so yeah that's
what we're gonna do miss Jimmy I'm just
gonna sing a duet with that just
happened but she did good though it was
good eyes it was terrifying and fun and
all of it yeah it's great
quite wrap your brain around what you
were going to do or I mean that's kind
of fearless fearless yes or fearful
depending on how you look at it I mean
we I but I had you know dolly and Linda
of Perry there too who were just patient
and wonderful and I mean it's a it's a
interesting to be a behind one of those
little circular mesh things I know
Nemean and I mean I just sort of had
this weird
you know dream of a lifetime just come
crashing in on me and it was happening
yeah and in a rock star
it was yes such a I mean all of them
those guys who do that it's it's it's
quite that it's fantastic but she did a
good job though I have to say she's a
little nervous it's a start but she
wished and walked in there actually does
everything else like a real pro she put
those headphones on and she was little
nervous I could tell but we've had but I
sang through it and then got my voice
literally had barely it couldn't even
have a squeak come out and then when we
finished I remember I just burst into
tears I know she did a harmony part too
you know Linda worked with her and she
did it actually a good heart but she did
she could did get emotional after she
was done well you know you I would
imagine if I ever were to jump out of an
airplane yeah I would probably have the
same reaction of like I just did that
you know kid singing into parishes and
yes wanting to be you know a rock star
or whatever or a singer of any kind
well I sing Dolly Parton and Diana Ross
when I was a kid yeah don't you listen
and were you a big fan I was jolly I was
yes Barry Manilow I remember Satan also
thinking I was Barry Manilow now I have
to say I'm a country girl not seven but
I'm country and I would say the accent
was very good what do you would you
think about the exit I thought she did
great and I told her that I went to see
it with her I had not seen it and I was
sitting right by her and I was really
impressed and I knew she worried about
it because she hadn't she didn't know
she needed to hear it from somebody but
news yeah so I leaving I said it's great
it's a great job and she said to get it
a wonderful dialect coach okay like I
love picking up on accents anyway it's
just something I I've always sort of
been able to do a little bit but and
that one is in particular so yeah but I
also have a fantastic dialect coach who
just sort of would give me little tips
here and there what's the toughest thing
Don't Tell many times I hear people go
they'll go to here and that's just not
country you know what I'm saying so
they'll go to a weird like a comical
version what a southern accent is yeah
and we hate that so what's the toughest
thing about getting it like just right
not knowing if you got it right I know
how many just hurt by my mom's pageant
season she already started her guy all
right dumpling the other side
oh okay darlin just grab my ankles one
of the scenes that I cracked up laughing
that was when you're laying down in the
car when you're on the way and you can
because you can't like sit in your dress
right so I I would think maybe you've
had that experience with what's the
crazy experience you've had me you're
like going to an award show in a bit I
have to well I haven't actually worn I
mean there is in the moments where I've
had to sit sort of sideways and you
can't sort of bend your legs so there's
been that but I'm never at you know
there's certain when those girls that
I've never been to the Met Gala you know
that big or where their dresses are so
big I just can't imagine how they've
gotten into anything and then turns out
they all were in huge vans buses where
they have to stand up and I've I've yet
to have that it's true how would you say
that Hollywood is most like the pageant
world
hmm Hollywood moves like the pageant
world interesting thing cuz they dress
up they always feel it you don't have to
be over done or they'd have to always be
made up you have to be so precise then
you know be especially like if you don't
award shows it's very much like please
tell them up addresses yeah of a going
out there and sort of putting on your
sparkly pretty pretty self we love that
you're doing the project with Rhys now
the team how has that been partnering
with her
I'm just keep pinching myself from this
to that I mean I'm just I don't know
what to say I am we started shooting
like about a month ago and it has been
just so much fun it is hard it is dense
and is but it is so fulfilling yeah so I
do a lot of what you do yeah oh by the
way there might be a battle now who's
the biggest BFF of dolly you Reese
because she loves her son dolly oh I
know she does actually you just send her
a little video oh we doing we will we
will she's why they were equal yeah I
mean she's a little more a little and
she used to dress up like me which is
tiny little things over things but I've
known her so long and she's a Tennessee
girl we both live in Nashville man her
shop he's right next door to my office
so when she does boy do I get a chance
to see her but I'm I'm so excited that I
have a new friend now Jennifer no chance
I've met her before but when we got to
work on this project
she's so easy to love and she is she's
so easy to like and she's friendly and
all the stuff that you want her to be
that my husband all he he's always had a
crush on her
and he's always said well what she like
is she is nice and she think she's means
she's pretty and she's a yes yes and yes
it's true gee you you realize you are
all of our girlfriends in our heads like
we all feel like Jen Aniston is our
friend
yeah that's I'm so I'm here to serve
what I owe to your dolly parton say
Jimmy
Jennifer Aniston is my friend I'm dying
on the inside crying and I'm like you
know I'm just it's just been pinch me
pinch me exciting this is really cool I
love it you're a producer on this yeah
yep and they created a little bit of a
fan frenzy yesterday when they posted
that they were gonna end friends at the
end of the year and it was a mistake oh
it's not happen is that what but people
but it's coming up on the 25th
anniversary what of what no 25 years of
what like since it was thought of is 25
years like since it began that's a mind
warp my brain just warped to have
decades yeah that's that's a long I mean
that's just that's just very strange
because it feels like yesterday yeah it
really does
feels like yesterday we had the we've
all gathered together and watch to the
premiere of the the pilot Wow
so that was 25 years ago everything is
just so good you know just it holds yeah
absolutely
[Music]